yeah that's my blood that's my life is a
lot of my blood
Oh
okay it's okay
No
ah
ah
buy me a drink sailor Harry Flynn hey
hell are you doing here I'm looking for
you mate Oh should I be flattered or
worried maybe a bit of buzz come here
I've got a job for us really my client
is willing to part with a huge sum of
cash if we acquire a certain object for
him Adam listening yeah you're not gonna
like this oh no no you're out of your
mind you just hear me out in SF Lin we
both know two people who were killed
trying to lift something out of this
place one who made it out yeah barely I
can't do this without you Drake you're
the only one is cracked it and you're
not better than anyone it's a two-person
job no no three actually right it's
bigger the devil here she comes now what
Louis Fraser Nate Drake Nathan Drake
hello Harry Chloe has one of the best
drivers in the business she'll take good
care of us I bet all right look I've got
it all figured out go in through the
sewer loving it so far that puts us in
the courtyard from there we scale up the
wall run across the rooftops and just
drop down into the exhibit hall bob's
your uncle and what is worth all this
trouble I hear you ask I didn't but go
ahead but that's it an oil lamp yeah
it's worthless I don't get it neither do
we that's why we tracked you down well
it sounds like you're working for a
nutcase hmm some collector who's got too
much time and money on his hands and by
the way this is not worth any of it but
there's more
how's your 13th century latin night
where'd you get this borrowed it from
the files of the nutcase